melissa is with us in Salt Lake City hi
Melissa how are you doing great day
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
well my husband and I need a little
counsel we have been following your baby
steps for six years now we own our home
so we are debt-free and feeling really
happy about it we've been debt-free for
about seven months but we feel like
we've lost a lot of the intensity and
the purpose with which we live life
while we were getting out of debt like I
never feel like I could ever say that I
miss being on that tight budget where I
couldn't buy orange juice and I had to
like make my own shorts out of my old
jeans but I miss it and so my question
is what is it you missed you don't miss
the sacrifice what is it yes I miss the
purpose I know I miss sitting down with
him at the table and coming to each
other with like you know how we were
attacking this debt and all the progress
that we made and it's not as fun sitting
down and being like so we bought a table
you know we're putting a little money
into the home we're investing which is
great we love investing and we're
hitting that really hard too we make
about 60,000 and a year and we're
investing about 1,300 a month right now
Wow and yeah so you think it would take
us enough but like when we sit down at
the table we we kind of feel like you
know what should we do to the house now
and it's just not as invigorating as it
was when I'd save like $10 on the
utility bill you know and like we just
lost a lot of that intensity that we
live life with and we're looking for
purpose like we've lost our big white we
own our home and it is freeing and it's
great and he's taking time off and we
get to be together as a family and
that's great but like we've lost our we
love finances and we just have lost that
fire that we live like what you've lost
is you don't have a Y that you care
deeply enough about exactly we all right
everyone she's still in there so you
need to you
to spend some time defining your why
because you're just generally building
wealth to build wealth but you need to
have young children did you have choice
but it's a long way the way do you have
children yes we have three okay then you
need to sit down and think about in
detail what their lives will be like
when you hit some of these wealth
building goals because our first y was
based in your first whys based on
desperation and it's kind of the old
psych 101 class you know remember taking
psychology in high school even the pain
and pleasure principal pain pain
avoidance is more motivating than
pleasure seeking for the human animal
and and what you've done is you the
first portion was pain avoidance you
know not going broke not being in the
street not being homeless not whatever
and getting out of debt to do all of
that that was pain avoidance now you're
looking for pleasure seeking and so and
pleasure seeking has to have the Y has
to have a soul based nobility to it it
can't simply be a new kitchen table
that's too dry yeah okay now you can
have some minor goals in there that we
want to renovate the house or we want to
go on a cruise around the world or we
want to do this or that but you need to
define very clearly what change your
family tree means and when you get that
really down there and then you start
looking at the kids and you you know
you'll shift some of your intensity to
teaching the children to be good with
handling money because if you don't
you're going to build so much wealth
that's going to ruin their lives because
if you leave a bunch of wealth to a
bunch of ignoramuses you've destroyed
their lives and so you have to turn that
intensity and that's how you can even
see it in the books I've written the
phase that we went through the first
book was financial peace right the
second book was total money makeover
that's kind of like the first stages
right of what you went through and then
contrary leadership was which was
running our business and then guess what
smart money smart kids generational and
you know what the next one was legacy
journey you set you can follow my books
and follow how my wife
changed as I went along and my why's a
whole lot bigger than just getting out
of debt these days and I work harder
right now than I ever have so you need
to more clearly define your why and make
it more noble and more detailed and that
will help you with your intensity good
question
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]